bestimmt das alter was ist das was du
davon herzlich willkommen beim ein video
ja leute heute steht was krasses an ich
habe keine ahnung warum ich in meinem
zimmer anfange aber eben rosig anfangs
auf jeden fall war ich letztens
einkaufen und ich bin so durch den laden
gegangen habe gedacht hey du hast ein
letztes mal so oder amazon box
ausgepackt dann hast du das mal
ausgepackt das kann man danach auspacken
und ich gehe durch den laden dagegen
überhaupt nichts böses und sehe dann
plötzlich so ein riesenhaufen kinder
überraschungseier im angebot das war
nicht irgendwie einfach eine ganz
normale situation älter sind
überraschungseier
ich habe mich wirklich in diesem moment
so geführt sowohl das ist für mich
bestimmt ja und wir haben jetzt keine
abend ich wollte das video jetzt aber
irgendwie mal beginnen und wir müssen
jetzt erst mal kaufen ich weiß noch
nicht wie viel ich hole muss ich mal
schauen also ich würde sagen lässt ob es
gleich
[Musik]
[Applaus]
ich habe diese auf die aufs kassenband
gelegt die mich so an sagt die dein
ernst trainiert fast 100 kommen jetzt
haben wir's doch was zu tun für die
nächsten drei monate wohl jeden tag 13
monate
so leute herzlich willkommen zurück ich
hoffe ihr könnt mich gut verstehen auf
jeden fall bin ich erzähle in unserer
wohnung dauer ist nicht kaufleute ich
muss erst mal kurz ausholen moment ich
weiß und spaß augen ich was ich mir
dabei gedacht haben also als erstes
sollte nicht nur eine packung holen dann
habe ich hier noch der kommunist 200 und
dann hab ich gedacht hey wenn es schon
mal hier bist nimmst du einfach 30 wir
haben jetzt ja fast 100 stück davon und
und was ich erst mal sagen dass ich war
früher wirklich mega der fan vor diesen
teil ich wollte ich immer haben weil ich
meinen schmecken die echt gut und zum
anderen war werde ich echt coole sachen
mit dabei ich habe mich gesammelt ich
hatte eine ganze kiste soll voll mit
diesen dingern und ich bin im erst
einmal ziemlich gespannt was ich da so
dran geändert hat was ist jetzt zu sagen
gibt vielleicht ist ja auch was mercedes
drin weil was ich auch noch weiß es gab
wirklich vorteile wenn man diese unserer
ganzen sammlung hatte die waren wirklich
was wäre das war eigentlich mit pokémon
karten oder sonstwas und ich mich bemüht
als schon 17 jahre das ganz schön alt
und ich finde man sollte auch mal wieder
kind sein können ja das finde ich ganz
wichtig und deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
warum nicht passe doch einfach mal so
ein paar sachen aus mal sehen was du
dabei ist und vielleicht kommt das ja
ganz gut keine ahnung ich würde sagen
wenn dieses video 15.000 liter es ist
nur die frage sind bei kindern ist das
gleiche drin keine ahnung weil 15.000
lights mache ich das dann auch mal mit
kindern polen wenn ich mir fast 100
kinder wurde das kostet 100 euro das ist
kostet hunderte tor ist und 120 das
werde ich dann sehen also bei 15.000
likes versuche ich das dann auch mit
kindern wir fangen an ich nehme einfach
irgendwo raus zum teil
und ich bin mal gespannt was sich so
bekommen war das so geil aus einer diese
teile die glänzen so ich kann mich sogar
darin sehen nutzer wie so ist es jetzt
kaputt gegangen und ja ich gebe es zu
ich hab so wird der schokolade gut so
wir haben es ist das bei warum geht
diese scheiß mütze jetzt nicht hier
drauf also aber jetzt habe ich
verstanden
ach so ja sowas wirklich immer schon mal
haben
ich stelle das alles macht ihn so hier
hinten ist jetzt erst mal die
nur mehr zu sein wenn ich jetzt wirklich
jedes ei aus packe ich glaube das dauert
wobei ich habe ja auch noch kein video
was über eine stunde geht
hhs hab ich geschafft ein puzzle was
mittelpunkt scheiße ist das eigentlich
euer ernst also früher war das echt viel
kreativer ich mal als kleines kind freut
man sich doch immer so ein spielzeug und
einmal ist da noch zusammenbauen muss
dann ist die welt perfekt nur ich klicke
einfach ab er besteht aus dem appell und
dann noch dieses ding das besteht aus
was auch immer und wer denke ich mal
schneller
ich habe einfach ein auto
[Musik]
warum geht das jetzt nicht jammern
so dann machen wir mal weiter
ich saß jetzt locker drei minuten an dem
auto und ich hab's nicht zusammengebaut
bekommen jetzt ein haar drin guck mal
seht ihr das jetzt einfach den haaren
oder was auch immer und nur ein auto so
jetzt mach ich aber richtig erst kommt
das hier nämlich drauf oder so das kommt
hinten glaube ich dran und wo ich jetzt
das gummi für ach so jetzt hört man das
umbauen
hier ganz klar ich würde mal sagen jetzt
locker schon acht minuten rum und yahia
ausgepackt also das ist bis jetzt auf
jeden fall mit abschluss kurz bevor
wirklich alle minions ich weiß nicht wie
viele gibt es da dann ist das sicherlich
eine menge wert oder auch nicht so wir
gucken mal was man noch zu haben
jetzt hat mein mitbewohner wenigstens
für die nächsten wochen was zu essen was
ist das keine ahnung ist langweilig man
früher war das viel geiler irgendwie so
ein drachen der in einem 18 games
ortsnähe die sind anders aus weiß ich
nicht das ist kommt gruppen will
hier muss doch irgendwo was drin sein
was mich so richtig schlecht mal gucken
was hier drin ist ohne spaß was ist das
ich dachte erst das wäre ein trampolin
aber irgendwie die ach so das ist das
ist ja das ist eine schildkröte
aber ganz ehrlich so sehen schildkröten
nicht aus mal sehen was es noch so wird
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 habe ich schon
ausgepackt fehlen und auch 80
was genau bist du kann mir irgendjemand
sagen was das sah das passt zu meinem
publikum genau die gleiche farbe das
teil kann was man tut ihr das ding ins
maul
ok es kann doch nichts mal sehen was
hier so jetzt bin ich mal gespannt
ok wat ich muss erstmal das zeug hier
weg räumen
[Applaus]
bestimmt das alter was ist das also als
richter auf jeden fall
es riecht nach kokosnuss
jetzt habe ich den ganzen tisch haut
ganz ehrlich wer tun dass sie rein
jetzt ist das also ich mache nur sauber
aber war das nicht schlimm
stellt euch mal vor ein dreijähriges
kind ist das dann eher leute irgendwie
kommen wir gar nicht voran
was soll das sein
kannst du mir sagen hat so das soll
hüpfen können gar nicht mal schlecht
warte kleinem makel im tisch ja ganz
toll die leute ohne spaß das video geht
schon eine halbe ewigkeit ich glaube das
ist jetzt erstmal das letzte mit dem
rest habe ich wenigstens was ich könnte
theoretisch auch in zeiten wenn ihr das
wollt schreibt jetzt sofort heftig in
die kommentare
oder ich es halt einfach alleine auf
jeden tag zwei eier da habe ich
eineinhalb monate dann sind sie weg
sowas haben wir ja noch drin und noch
ein auto astor des autos so krass das
kann sogar die flüge würden meinte das
kann fliegen sollte auf jeden fall die
frage ist jetzt was machen immer diesen
sachen ich habe ideen kommen damit okay
leute kommt mal kurz mit
[Musik]
was der kommission
deswegen begrüßen
ja hier der geschäftsstart sind das ist
viel wert in der sammlung eine kleine
kleine kinder würden nicht nur freunde
du bist ja mal versuchen erstmal dazu es
war auf jeden fall eine erfahrung für
sich aber ich durfte mich mal wieder
kurz fühlen wie 7 oder vier werde ich
den rest ja auch noch auspacken soll
statt sie die kommentare mit kinder zu
15.000 likes ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
kinder deutschen werken noch 10.000 mal
besser als so was aber wir werden sehen
will sonst freitag wieder etwas dazu
sagen auf jeden fall ab und yahoo